and don't ever come down there will be
no judging of cocaine bear we're all
like that when it comes to what to watch
but luckily that's where we come in to
help coming at you this week one movie
in theaters is definitely not for the
whole family and another movie that
thankfully is plus a couple of great
streaming Series where one is returning
after a decade break and finally we have
even better reasons to catch a little
big movie that dominated this past
weekend you know the drill fresh family
Rotten Tomatoes has got you covered on
this week's what to watch
high on cocaine
out of its mind while the title should
be enough reason to see it the true
story this horror comedy is based on is
even better allow me in 1985 a Georgia
black bear consumed a valued two million
dollars worth of cocaine that had been
unloaded mid-flight from a plane being
used to traffic the drugs and along with
being directed by Elizabeth Banks you
have a stellar ensemble cast which
includes Carrie Russell Margo Martindale
the legendary Ray Liotta in one of his
final performances R.I.P and O'Shea
Jackson Jr and Alden Aaron Reich who if
this clip is any indication of what
we're in for have some great chemistry
all that is the first is the first
person I've ever worked with he winds up
into whatever the first line of the
scene is he's getting that engine going
and once it's going the lawnmower is on
baby lawnmower the lawnmower man the
lawnmower man over here
no no
[Music]
in other hazy white substances that may
make you run and scream news Netflix's
Adventure comedy we have a ghost
premieres now if you haven't yet docked
into the David Harbor then this movie
might be a good start because the guy is
in everything and he never fails to be
loved and so does the rest of the cast
you have Jennifer Coolidge whose star
has never shown brighter Anthony Mackey
who's a gosh dang superhero and
tignataro who is always funny plus we
have a ghost was written and directed by
Christopher Landon who's made a name for
himself in the horror Biz by co-writing
and directing a bunch of hits like the
recent freaky a bunch of installments in
the Paranormal Activity franchise and
writing 2007's Disturbia and I want to
leave this section on an interesting
thought it goes surreal then we
definitely all have a ghost great good
night I need to watch your mouth maybe I
am on the wrong team we can't be friends
anymore spending a second season on the
peacock playground is the drama series
Bel Air coming almost exactly one year
after the fresh first season premiered
of course this is the reimagined version
of the 90s sitcom The Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air and was developed from a fan
film that caught the attention of the
original series star Will Smith and if
that story isn't reason enough to watch
this show I don't know what is well I
actually do it's Jabari Banks he plays
the fictional version of Will Smith in
what is his very first acting credit
ever plus he's from West Philadelphia
born and raised you know the rest but
don't take my word for it top RT critic
Melanie McFarlane from salon.com
credited banks for making the series
work saying he has a lively Swagger that
emerges more readily as the series goes
on
this is no joke
this is catering now if you're down for
the kind of party that hasn't been
thrown in a while perhaps the return of
party down on stars is where you want to
be and while the series does include
Paul Rudd as one of its co-creators the
main reason to watch is that you
actually can because it's actually back
party down was canceled in 2010 after
two seasons due to low ratings despite
critical Acclaim but now a six episode
Revival has come 13 years later with
most of the original cast returning like
Adam Scott Jane Lynch Ken Marino Megan
Mullally and others and if you like to
put your trust in the Tomato Meter which
you should another major reason to tune
in is that all three seasons are fresh
including a certified fresh fur season a
100 fresh second season and a currently
94 fresh third season
I'm sorry Cassie
and finally in our catch-up pick of the
week in Ant-Man and the WASP quanta
Mania opening weekend the audience gave
us a bunch of new reasons why you may
want to catch this in its second week or
beyond the audience score for
quantumania is at a high 84 percent with
over 5 000 verified audience reviews
Colin M who gave the film 5 out of 5
Stars said best Marvel installments
since end game and it's not even close
both quality riding plus connection to a
broader story and the most ambitious
thing that Marvel has ever done from a
VFX perspective you also have Erica s
who gave the film four and a half stars
out of five and said Marvel has redeemed
itself with this movie the last few
additions really ruined it for me but
this movie was entertaining funny and
spot on alright hopefully these IDs will
be just what you need to unwind and take
in a little r r this weekend be sure to
let us know what you watch whether was
on the list or or not and always
remember to check in on
rottentomatoes.com for updates on the
latest scores and reviews and until next
week stay fresh
[Music]